la parole est à madame nathalie
koscuisko morizet merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
ma question porte sur la police
municipale à paris demain s'achève in
extremis la navette parlementaire sur le
statut de paris et cela restera une
illustration supplémentaire d'un
sectarisme dont paris fait les frais et
dont les parisiens paye le prix
au cours de la discussion les députés
parisiens l'opposition sont montré
constructif et innovant mais aucun je
dis bien aucun des amendements qu'ils
ont présentées n'ont été examinés avec
sérieux par le gouvernement et sa
majorité
alors c'est au nom de tous mes collègues
de paris et au delà au nom de tous les
élus parisiens de la droite et du centre
représentant je vous le rappelle une
majorité des voix des parisiens que je
veux vous dire notre lassitude devant
cette attitude ni sur la circulation ni
sur les compétences et arrondissements
ni même sur la sécurité
nous n'avons été entendu faute d'être
seulement écouter et sur la sécurité
justement alors on les forces de la
préfecture de police sont légitimement
mobilisés dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
on mesure tout ce que la police
municipale tous qu'une police municipale
pourrait faire face à la petite
délinquance du quotidien qui s'accroît
et qui dégrade la vie tous les vols les
trafics la mendicité agressive
paris est la seule grande ville à ne pas
disposer d'une police municipale
la loi sur le statut de paris c'était
l'occasion de la créer et vous avez
pourtant rejeté balayé cette proposition
de bon sens
comme toutes les autres quasiment sans
débat alors monsieur le premier ministre
ma question est simple pourquoi vous
obstinez vous si ce n'est pour
satisfaire le dogmatisme d'anne hidalgo
a refusé à paris une police municipale
comme en justice
d'après le plus longtemps les parisiens
eux bruno le roux ministre de
l'intérieur madame la députée kosciusko
morizet savez l'expression police
municipal désigne à la fois vous le
savez les pouvoirs de police municipale
et le corps d'agents qui est chargé de
leur exécution et je voudrais vous
répondre très précisément
s'agissant de paris la police municipale
la police municipale à paris a pour
objet d'assurer le bon ordre la sûreté
la sécurité et la salubrité publique est
ce qui distingue paris des autres villes
vous le savez c'est l'autorité qui
exerce les pouvoirs à paris le préfet de
police constitue l'autorité de droit
commun en lieu et place du maire qui
détient quant à lui une compétence
d'attribution sont les questions de
sécurité le projet de loi de paris dont
vous parlez élargi d'ailleurs la
compétence d'attribution du maire de
paris qui se verra confier de nouvelles
responsabilités et des pouvoirs
renforcés en matière de police je pense
sur les édifices qui menace de ruine sur
la sécurité des immeubles collectifs à
usage d'habitation sur les baignades les
rassemblements à caractère festive
récréatif ou culturel
et il s'agit donc de nouvelles missions
qui sont donnés à la police elles
peuvent vous sembler trop petite elle
existe et vous avez tort de les nier
à paris les missions d'exécution la
police municipale ne relève certes pas
de policiers municipaux mais elles sont
confiées à 1711 agents de surveillance
de paris les asp qui sont chargées les
mêmes missions que les agents de police
municipale et que le projet de loi
transfère au maire de paris
il s'agit donc d'agents de la ville de
paris qui sont placés sous l'autorité du
maire et donc je suis heureux de vous
apprendre madame la députée qu'il existe
donc bien une police municipale à paris
et le projet de loi pour oblivion de
placer les agents qu'il exécute dans
leur totalité sur l'autorité du maire le
pipeau c'est peut-être le fait que la
situation que vous connaissez dans
l'essonne n'était pas celle que vous
découvrez à paris aujourd'hui de ce
point de vue là vous auriez tort de
contester ce qui est
réalité de ce qui est dans le projet de
loi qui est débattue à l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui
merci